yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm breaking down the ending of
cobra kai season 3 what it means for
season 4 and revealing all the clever
details and secret easter eggs to
previous seasons and all the karachi kid
movies
spoilers ahead of course so take care
after several seasons of will they won't
they
daniel and johnny have finally joined
karate forces to solve their shared
problem
how to give kris and his cobra kai the
chop for good
teaching crease a lesson wasn't really
something daniel thought he was up to
before as he told us back in the 80s
that guy just doesn't know what karate
is all about yeah well maybe he should
learn
would you like to teach him no i
wouldn't be surprised if we see that
moment mentioned in some way in season
four after all the showrunners are
self-professed superfans that go deep
with their references
from visual nods like fernandez meat
stickers to episode titles like ace
degenerate
you silly ace degenerate no ex
degenerate man indeed johnny's come
quite a way even just
this season i mean look at how in
episode one he's punching car windows
allah john crease but by the end he
couldn't be further removed from his old
sensei as he's teamed up with his old
rival
as mr miyagi put it in one of his
letters that kumiko reads to danny in
life we always lose our way but
it is people not the signs that guide us
back
to the right path now the season finale
saw friends who'd become enemies
reunited as friends once more
and while daniel and johnny might not be
best buds exactly
so have the man boys filled you in on
the whole mortal enemy karate dojo
battling for the soul the valley thing
they are allies now at least so they're
on the right path
after all as ali told them and the truth
is you guys are more alike than you want
to admit
or as crease would say the enemy of your
enemy
is your friend interestingly when chris
said those words to hawke earlier this
season he was talking about robbie who'd
put their fellow cobra miguel in a coma
but had now
turned against daniel and miyagido so
it's clear that kris is just using
robbie to get what he wants
revenge you know when i was overseas it
was hard to tell who was the enemy in
fact
chris has got robbie so brainwashed
thinking that mercy is a weakness for
losers that he can't see crease as the
real enemy
not his dad or daniel i won't fight you
are weak
indeed robbie thinks crease is the good
guy now he wants what's best for you
given everything johnny knows about his
old sensei
seeing his kids side with him and the
way kris calls robbie son
must really hurt after all we saw how
johnny reacted when he discovered daniel
was training robbie in season one
still as daniel told johnny this season
the whole reason these kids got into
trouble was because of us
we can't let them suffer because of our
issues the only way to end this is by
working together
in other words just as crease told
daniel in episode one about their
eventual face-off
this was all inevitable and that's
because this whole situation
is as much about the past as it is about
the present the showrunners have said
they really care about their titles and
often tie them thematically to the
episode's content
and to the original movies and the date
in this title does both as it's the day
daniel beat johnny in the 1984 all
valley tournament
chris still hasn't got over what
happened that day as his whole
philosophy of life and karate
lost to mr miyagi's diametrically
opposed ethos
although his own actions afterwards
caused him to lose all his students and
go broke he placed the blame elsewhere
and while his and his old army buddies
schemes for payback at the next
tournament failed in the karate kid 3
he's obviously hoping it's third time
lucky
why don't we settle this the
old-fashioned way tournament
if we lose i go if you lose we won't
lose
but will crease actually leave
peacefully if he does lose
quite possibly not because as johnny
said you can't trust him by the way
notice how crease looks at johnny when
he says if you
lose because he's goading him about his
second place back in 1984
something crease took very personally
second place is no place you're off
you're nothing you're lost you're a
loser this season went into chris's
backstory and we learned that as a young
man he was more like hawk miguel or tori
dealing with a rough life family
hardships and bullies
and like them he took to heart some
flawed lessons from an authority
figure modeling himself after his
captain in vietnam
adopting not just his interest in
martial arts and his cigar habit
but most damagingly his kill or be
killed shed your humanity
merciless attitude kris led his students
down that same
wrong path and decades later one of them
did the same with his own students until
he wised up
but with chris in the cobra kai driving
seat again he's perpetuating the cruel
no-mercy cycle
passing it on to a new generation this
will never be overlord so you hear me
and treating school kids like they're in
a war the fight at the school was an
embarrassment
you lost soldiers and you lost the
battle fighting his mentor in vietnam
was a seminal moment for crease becoming
the man we know today
interestingly it only happened because
he stepped in to save his army pal silva
but when their allies arrived bringing
with them the possibility that both kris
and his captain could make it out of
their battle to the death alive
crease made a choice about the kind of
man he wanted to be
in a way in the finale johnny is also
only there
fighting his mentor because of someone
else his protege miguel who's been badly
beaten by the kobrakai kids
and just as crease took over from his
captain after their fight
season four will likely bring a similar
opportunity for johnny
but back in the here and now johnny
refuses to fight his son as
unlike crease he's no longer willing to
continue his mentor's merciless cycle
with the younger generation because as
he told his students
i wasn't taught the difference between
mercy and honor and i paid the price for
it in fact he even vetoed them fighting
dirty
the baddest badass is the one who beats
his opponent when he's at his strongest
not when his back is turned but just as
kris's captain tried to exploit his
humanity by revealing his girlfriend's
death right before their fight
crease himself is happy to take
advantage of johnny's humanity
as he tends to his unconscious son and
look what's in shot right after that
an all valley tournament poster
reminding us what this is all about
and how it will end crease reverts to
his old karate kid part 2 ways when he
starts to choke
johnny it's not the first time we've
seen chris get him in a choke hold in
this series
though last time he was demonstrating
the moving class rather than actually
trying to take him out
but as crease said at the top of the
season he thought he and johnny would be
fighting daniel together which is what i
think he means when he tells johnny this
isn't how i wanted this to end
and the way he kicks johnny away here
after choking him
reminds me of how johnny pushed chris
away after using the chokehold on him
when he first arrived back in season two
as for how crease deals with daniel when
he turns up let's just say there's
definitely a recurring theme of smashing
his opponents into glass in the show
which is likely a callback to when he
and his buddy silva fought mr miyagi in
the third karachi kid movie
of course in the second movie kris also
kept smashing his fists into car windows
as he failed repeatedly to punch danny
sensei
and while kris can't stop resorting to
dirty tactics
time for you and miyagi to reunite he's
once again outmaneuvered by miyagido
techniques
this time the secret pressure points
that chosen taught dany
if an enemy insists on war then you take
away their ability to wage it
given he was interrupted by his daughter
i wonder if next season they'll address
how dany would have ended that fight
it certainly didn't feel like he was
going out in mr miyagi style
a couple of other interesting details
here are the colours daniel and johnny
are wearing reminiscent of their
showdown at the end of the first film
also this image of sam with her father
and miguel beside johnny just as robbie
arrives would doubtless reinforce in
robbie's mind his earlier accusation
that his dad treats miguel more like a
son than him
and just as a season two finale used a
phone to foreshadow the return of
another original movie character for the
next season
this time a phone call by crease lets us
know that the third film's main villain
his army pal terry silva will be turning
up in season four
in the show a young silva goes by the
nickname twig and only makes it out of
vietnam alive thanks to his friend
i owe you man you stay my ass anything
you need
i'm there for you you hear me johnny
your whole life i owe you
given the phone call then it looks like
we'll see actor thomas ian griffith who
played silva in the movie back in action
especially as he said only last year
that it'd be fun to see the whole gang
again
silva's been happily repaying kris's
life saving over the years from founding
kobrakai for him to wreaking revenge on
daniel and miyagi when kris went out of
business
and with just how much silver reveled in
sneaking around and inflicting
pain and humiliation back in the 80s i'm
sure he'll love teaming up with crease
again to give daniel johnny and their
students a taste of the nasty medicine
he thinks they deserve for everything
they've done to his old army friend
i wonder what devious schemes he'll
dream up this time
now when it came to fighting silver and
crease in the movie mr miyagi
easily defeated them but how will daniel
and johnny do in the show
of course ralph macchio and william
zabka are the stars of the series so
they'll certainly triumph in the end
but the writers have got ten episodes
that's over five hours compared to a two
hour movie
so i imagine we'll get some standoffs
between the adult leads before their
final big showdown
and a lot of training and confrontations
for the younger characters before the
tournament
and if you haven't had enough cobra car
yet you can discover more of the amazing
details cleverly hidden in the show in
my things you missed video
tap here to watch that or follow the
link in the video description
so what did you think of the latest
season and what would you like to see
happen in season 4
leave your comments below and if you
enjoyed this don't forget to leave a
thumbs up
it's hugely appreciated now tap left for
my next video or tap right for something
else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee kai movie lovers